.
HAVE A GREAT WEEKEND, WE WILL
SEE YOU MONDAY.
>> THIS IS "THE INGRAHAM ANGLE"
FROM LOS ANGELES TONIGHT.
RIGHT NOW WE ARE MONITORING
ELECTION RESULTS INTO STATES,
ARIZONA AND NEVADA, THE DECISIO
DESK IS PRETTY PREDICTING THE
GOVERNORSHIP IS FLIPPING FROM
DEMOCRAT TO REPUBLICAN.
INCUMBENT GOVERNOR STEVE TO
SELECT PUTTING OUT A CONCEDING
THAT HE WILL FALL SHORT OF
WINNING AND HE WISHED REPUBLICA
SHERIFF JOB EMBARGO MUCH SUCCESS
.
IN ARIZONA, AND HE MOMENT, WE
ARE EXPECTING A NEW VOTE COUNT
FROM MARICOPA COUNTY.
ABOUT 80,000 BALLOTS OR SO BUT
THAT COULD CHANGE.
MORE THAN 50 PERCENT OF THOSE
ARE BALLOTS THAT WERE THEN
DROPPED OFF ON ELECTION DAY.
WE WILL BRING YOU THE DETAILS A
THEY COME IN THIS HOUR.
FIRST, WRONG LESSONS, THAT IS
THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S ANGLE.
IT WAS PREDICTABLE, THE GOP
ESTABLISHMENT WHICH HAS BEEN
LOSING ELECTION SINCE ABOUT 200
WOULD DECLARE THE REPUBLICANS
DISAPPOINTING MIDTERM SHOWING
THE DEATHKNELL FOR POPULIST.
THE RATIONALE BEING THAT BECAUS
CERTAIN TRUMPET BACKED
CANDIDATES LOST IN KEY RACES,
THE ENTIRE POPULIST MOVEMENT
LOST TO.
>> UNDER REPUBLICANS THEY HAVE
TO REJECT THE ROBB EXPERT IF
THEY.
>> THE MAGA.
GIG AT THE FAVORITE LIBERAL
MASQUERADING AS SOMETHING MORE
SOPHISTICATED DID A FEVER
FINALLY BREAKING.
PERFORMATIVE POPULISM HAS BEGUN
TO EBB, AND TRUMPS REALISTIC
VIOLENCE THAT LAY AT THE HEART
OF IT ALL WRITING IN THE NEW
YORK TIMES HE STRUCK A SIMILAR
NOTE, ARGUING THAT TUESDAY'S
RESULTS BY STRIKING RESEMBLANCE
TO THE MIDTERM ELECTIONS OF 199
WHEN SETBACK THAN LEAD TO
RENEWAL.
WHEN THE PARTY THEN WENT ON TO
EMBRACE TEXAS GOVERNOR GEORGE W
BUSH WHO HAD RUN REELECTION OF
COURSE IN 1998 IN TEXAS.
WORD TO THE WISE, IF YOU'RE
ACTUALLY TRYING TO HELP RHONDA
SANTOS IN 2024, LET'S NOT MAKE
COMPARISON TO THE PRESIDENT WHO
HASN'T BEEN INVITED TO SPEAK AT
ANY RNC CONVENTION SINCE HE LEF
OFFICE.
BUT THE PRO WAR COALITION IS
VERY BOLD, YOU HAVE TO FACTS.
THEY ARE MARCHING TOGETHER LED
BY THEIR FALLEN STAR GENERAL LI
CHENEY WHO IS ENJOYING THE
MOMENT HERSELF, FALSELY
BELIEVING THAT TUESDAY'S RESULT
MEAN AMERICA IS HANKERING FOR
THE GOOD OLD DAYS OF FALLUJA AN
KANDAHAR.
>> IT WAS A CLEAR VICTORY FOR
TEAM NORMAL.
I DO THINK IT WAS THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE GENERALLY SENDING A
MESSAGE THEY WANT TO PULL AS
BACK FROM THE BRINK.
THEY DON'T WANT THIS NATION TO
GO OVER THE EDGE.
WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
INCENTIVES ARE THERE TO ELECT
THE KIND OF PEOPLE WHO ARE GOIN
TO MAKE SURE THEY ARE PART OF
THE SOLUTION.
>> IS CHENEY ACTUALLY SAYING
THAT SHE, A REPUBLICAN REJECTED
BY HER OWN VOTERS IN HER OWN
STATE, WHO LIVES INEXISTENT HOL
DERIVATIVE OF DONALD TRUMP, THA
SHE IS ON TEAM NORMAL?
SHE HAS VOWED TO FIGHT RHONDA
SANTOS AS WELL AS I RECALL.
SO FOR ALL INTENTS AND PURPOSES
SHE IS A PRO- WAR DEMOCRATS.
AT WAR WITH A 74 MILLION WHO
VOTED FOR TRUMP IN 2020 BECAUSE
THEY WERE DONE WITH THE BUSH
CHENEY ALTERNATIVES.
FOR REINVENTING THE GOP IN
SETTING THE PARTY ON THE PATH T
BEING A MULTIRACIAL
WORKING-CLASS PARTY.
YOU BET HE DESERVES CREDIT FOR
THAT AND A LOT MORE.
THINK ABOUT THAT SHAPE THE GOP
WAS BACK IN FIRST OF ARE COMING
IT WAS A BORING PARTY, IT WAS
STUCK IN A 2004 TIME WORKED
WORKED WITHOUT APPROACH AND
TOTALLY NOT IN SYNC WITH THE
CONCERNS OF AVERAGE AMERICANS.
>> BELIEVE THE GREAT MAJORITY O
PEOPLE COMING HERE ILLEGALLY
HAVE NO OTHER OPTION I WANT TO
PROVIDE FOR THEIR FAMILY.
THERE IT SHOULD BE A PATH TO
EARN STATUS.
>> OTHER THAN THE TEA PARTY
VICTORIES, WHERE WAS THE
EXCITEMENT AND GROWTH AND THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
HASN'T HAD MUCH ENERGY REALLY
SINCE ABOUT 1996 WHEN PITCHFORK
PAT BUCHANAN THE POPULACE AHEAD
OF HIS TIME WHEN HE WON THE NEW
HAMPSHIRE PRIMARY.
BEFORE 2016 THEY WERE LOSING TH
WORKING-CLASS VOTERS, THOSE
REAGAN DEMOCRATS WHERE THEY WER
FALLING AWAY.
THEY WERE ALSO FAILING TO
CONNECT WITH HISPANICS BACK THE
AND LET'S NOT FORGET REPUBLICANS
, THEY WERE HELPING
CHINA GET RICHER AND MORE
POWERFUL AS MORE AMERICANS OF
COURSE HAD THEIR JOBS SHIPPED
OVERSEAS.
OBAMA BEAT BOTH OF THEIR
ESTABLISHMENT CANDIDATES IN 200
AND THEN 2012.
McCAIN AND ROMNEY WERE AN ALUM
ANNIHILATED, FLORIDA WHEN
DEMOCRATS IMPOSE CYCLES AND IN
THE PROCESS HE CHALKED UP TO
SUPREME COURT JUSTICES WOULD
HAVE HAD THREE IF IT WEREN'T FO
McDONALD.
THE ESTABLISHMENT GOP HAD
EMBRACED GLOBALISM IN ENDLESS
WAR THEY HAD OVERSEEN THE
FLATTENING OF AMERICANS WEALTH,
AND PRESIDED OVER THE 2008
ECONOMIC MELTDOWN.
ALL THE WHILE PLEA PAYING LIP
SERVICE TO SOCIAL CONSERVATIVES.
TRUMP CAME IN AND TURNED THAT
ALL AROUND.
FAST-FORWARD TO TODAY.
I'M NOT GOING TO DWELL ON TRUMP
DUSTUP WITH OTHER POTENTIAL 202
NOMINEES, BUT AS FAR AS DESANTI
IS CONCERNED, TO KEEP YOUR EYE
ON THE ESTABLISHMENT TYPES THAT
START THROWING MONEY AT HIM FOR
BIG GOVERNMENT COALITION
REPRESENTING WALL STREET BIG
DEFENSE CONTRACTORS, BIG TECH,
THEY ARE ALREADY CIRCLING PAIR
THEY ARE GOING TO TRY TO CO-OP
HIM AND CHANGE HIM AND
EVENTUALLY, THEY WILL TRY TO
SWALLOW HIM WHOLE.
>> HIS POPULISM, DISSING IT MOR
POPULAR DOES HE REPLACE TRIM AN
A FRIENDLY WAY OR DOES HE
REPLACE TRUMP AND SORT OF MOVE
BACK MORE TO THE MIDDLE PARETSK
AT THINK THE ADJUSTERS ARE GOIN
TO BE THERE, I THINK IT'S GOING
TO BE MORE MAINSTREAM.
IN TERMS OF WHAT WALL STREET
WANTS.
>> WHAT WALL STREET WANTS, WHAT
CORPORATE AMERICA WANTS FOR IT
WHEN YOU PICK A FIGHT WITH
DISNEY TODAY.
>> PICKING A FIGHT WITH DISNEY?
DISNEY WAS PICKING A FIGHT WITH
PARENTS, ANDREW.
NOW POPULISM ISN'T EXTREME, IT'
PRAGMATIC.
THERE WAS PLENTY OF GOOD NEWS
FOR REPUBLICANS AT THE MEDIA
SEEK TO IGNORE, THE AND ROADS
MADE IN NEW YORK, THE CLOSER
THAN EXPECTED RACES IN THE
PACIFIC NORTHWEST, THEY
CONTINUED SHIFT OF HISPANIC
VOTERS AND OF COURSE THE HUGE
POPULACE EXPANSION IN TEXAS AND
OF COURSE IN FLORIDA.
PRETTY BOY BETO LAST BY ALMOST
100-POINT TO ABBETT.
AND CONSERVATIVE DAN PATRICK WA
REELECTED AS LIEUTENANT GOVERNO
BY DOUBLE DIGITS AS WELL.
IF THE ESTABLISHMENT REALLY HAS
ALL THE ANSWERS, HOW IS IT THAT
LISA MURKOWSKI DIDN'T SAIL TO
VICTORY IN ALASKA?
AND HOW DID ROMNEY GET
EMBARRASSED IN UTAH WHEN HE
REFUSED TO ENDORSE MIKE LEE WHO
ENDED UP WINNING HANDILY.
IF NOT TRUMP, WHOEVER RISES TO
THE PACK, WOULD BE BOMBARDED BY
THE ROMNEY CHENEY CROWD PAIR
THEY WILL PULL OUT EVERY STEP T
PUSH HIM OR HER TOWARD THE OLD
BUSH POLICIES OF ENDLESS WAR,
PARTNERING WITH THE CCP AND OPE
BORDERS.
HERE'S THE THING.
IT'S REALLY TOUGH IF YOU'RE A
REPUBLICAN TO AVOID GETTING
PUSHED IN THAT DIRECTION.
MUST GOP FOREIGN POLICY TYPE
SUPPORT THE BUSH FOREIGN POLICY.
MOST TRADE EXPERTS ARE PRO- CCP
IN PRO- WTO.
MUST GOP POLICY TYPES HAVE
SYMPATHY FOR GENEROUS
IMMIGRATION AMNESTY.
DESANTIS AND HIS TEAM WILL BE
WITH MEMORANDUM SUPPORTING ALL
OF THESE BAD IDEAS.
MY GUEST, AND IT'S JUST A GUESS
RIGHT NOW IS THAT HE AND ANY
SMART SERIOUS CANDIDATES WILL
CONSULT WITH EVERYONE AND THE
GOP, BUT AVOID THE ESTABLISHMEN
TRAP.
HOW CAN YOU CAMPAIGN WITH A
FRESH POPULIST MESSAGE THAT
AFFIRMATIVELY EMBRACES AMERICA
FIRS